welcome back to las vegas now dwane the
rock johnson is helping us celebrate
cinco de mayo with an easy margarita you
can you know make at home and spice
things up and of course with some guac
on the rock from three special locations
okay la comida peyote and 18 bin check
it out hey carrie welcome to las vegas
now welcome to our kitchen
good afternoon and happy cinco de mayo
[Music]
i got my fiesta dress on for you okay i
am ready for my channel
all right so explain what you're making
for us and why it's special so today we
will be making the people's margarita in
honor of both our founder dwayne johnson
whose birthday was just this week and
celebrating cinco de mayo and it's his
little spin on a regular margarita but
it's delicious and it's super easy to
make at home just requires a few
ingredients the first i'm going to rim
this glass with meldon sea salt
which is just like a fancy flaked sea
salt you can use regular salt as well
but this looks really pretty and special
it also has a really nice mouth feel and
a good salinity
and the most important ingredient the
rocks tequila of course the terra moda
tequila
which is 100 blue agave
that's grown in the highest region of
jalisco
um so it has a really beautiful
concentration of sweetness
and it's made in distilled in small very
very small batch copper pot stills so
very authentically made
um
bright refreshing lovely for a margarita
and then we're going to go in with
three quarters of an ounce of fresh lime
juice fresh is very important squeeze
your own lime juice don't buy that
bottled stuff that stuff is trash
just one ounce of pineapple juice and
then just a little bit of agave just to
give it a little bit of a touch of
sweetness and round it all out
yes half an ounce
and that's that's that's all there is to
the drink
so we're gonna put ice in our shaker ice
with our glass
now this is really special because it's
a little twist for the margarita but
it's still super approachable
it's got the shape like it owes me money
super approachable it's so refreshing
on a day like cinco de mayo when you may
be drinking all day who knows
it's good to have something that you can
have several of without being sick of it
you know and it's not but those are the
dangerous ones right where they're where
they're just so good you keep drinking
them
exactly so then we just fill it with ice
very important to have a little pretty
garnish
and that is our people's margarita i
just wanted to let you guys know that in
conjunction with um
for the week of cinco de mayo until the
8th we're doing this thing called walk
on the rock where if you go to a
restaurant and order a margarita with
taramana and they happen to have
guacamole on the menu you can order the
guacamole with your taramona drink
upload that picture of the receipt or of
your taramono cocktail on the walk to
walkontherock.com
and get 10 venmo to you from the rocks
personal account